deux invités est tout d'abord pour
débuter cette émission je me tourne vers
vous merci de nous recevoir tout d'abord
parce que nous sommes ici chez vous à
lille le loisir de saint quentin en
yvelines avec donc deux invités à
vincent couteau vous êtes responsable du
pôle événementiel et puis xavier quintin
vous êtes directeur des activités donc
de cette île de loisirs le mot d'ordre
pour cette saison c'est sport nature et
culture également et on va débuter avec
ce village sportif
jusqu'à quand est il proposé et qu'est
ce qu'on va pouvoir y trouver alors le
viage sportifs et culturels
il est en place depuis hier lundi
jusqu'à vendredi de la semaine prochaine
dont cap en deux semaines
on y trouve presque 25 activités aussi
bien sportif de l' escalade du rugby des
activités peu connus comme du tchoukball
football alors ça joue avec un
trampoline
il faut jeter la base sans trop peiner
l'a rattrapé avant qu'elles touchent le
sol pour marquer des points
voilà mais aussi d'activités culturelles
avec un atelier découverte des métiers
de la radio
une exposition sur l'olympisme et une
exposition sur les trajectoires plutôt
sport plutôt culture pendant les
vacances sports ça permet de bien tous
les excès de l'année puis la culture ça
fait du bien à l'esprit je sais pas pour
les autres
les autres pourront pas dire mieux
pareil et grégory sport oui vraiment
sports orlando sport pendant l'été c'est
important aussi on va faire un petit
tour du côté de ce village sportif
justement on se retrouve juste après ce
reportage
le hockey sur gazon la nouveauté du
village sportif et culturel 2019 à lille
de loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
des sports des activités culturelles
proposées aux jeunes de 11 à 17 ans
certains ateliers sont animés par des
sportifs de haut niveau c'est le cas de
jérémy aicardi anciens joueurs de
l'équipe de france de rugby à 7
si aujourd'hui j'ai envie de transmettre
c'est parce que tout ce que j'ai appris
pendant ma carrière en tout cas
professionnels mais surtout avancer les
valeurs du rugby le portage les copains
plaisir que le coach tangled ou pas te
félicite quand tu fais des belles
actions avec des créneaux d'une heure
par ateliers les jeunes peuvent
découvrir des sports inhabituel escalade
ventriglisse et sandball ou encore une
activité d'équitation d'une durée d'une
heure trente du sport mais pas seulement
également on pourra retrouver de
l'initiation aux gestes qui sauvent bas
pour apprendre justement les gestes de
premiers secours et sur la partie
culturelle on va retrouver notamment un
atelier radio avec l fm radio une
exposition du cnoss donc sur une
exposition autour des jeux olympiques
illégalement est intégré l'exposition
trajectoire j'ai une exposition sur la
mobilité le village sportif et culturel
c'est du 8 au 19 juillet
inscription obligatoire en 2018 près de
800 jeunes ont participé à cet événement
voilà pour ce village sportif c'est
l'une des nombreuses activités qui
seront proposées qui sera proposée ici à
lille de loisirs à saint quentin en
yvelines avant de parler des autres
rendez vous ils vous attendez beaucoup
de monde cet été
en général ils de loisirs fait le plein
en aspect on extrêmement liés à la météo
dont on a de la chance il fait beau il
fait pas trop chaud aujourd'hui parce
qu'on souffre effectivement également
des températures trop élevées
c'est aussi le risque est peut-être
aussi grand que le mauvais temps mais là
on a des conditions idéales et
apparemment ça se profile bien pour les
jours à venir
vous parliez des conditions météo
difficiles lorsqu'il fait trop chaud
mais on peut se rafraîchir depuis peu il
ya quelques saisons vous avez ouvert une
aire de jeu aussi tout à fait donc une
aire de jeux d'eau pour les 0-12 ans qui
paraît effectivement se rafraîchir et
qui sera de plus en plus de succès au
fil des années la la l'activité est bien
rodé maintenant et on a ouvert
j'ai un peu plus tôt cette année puisque
des femmes est en fait l'activité était
proposé vous avez bien fait puisque les
températures fin mai était déjà bien
élevé pour pouvoir en profiter et puis
je précise tout de même que les parents
aussi peuvent se rafraîchir avec avec
les enfants le pousse à lire on parlait
de deux cultures aussi sur cette île de
loisirs de saint quentin le pousse à
lire ça va permettre de lire partout
dans la base
exactement c'est vraiment la deuxième
édition donc de du pousse à lire avec
l'opération de partir en livres et
l'idée c'est d'amener
ballet les familles les jeunes à la
lecture est donc là on a on a un
pousse-pousse qui a été mis aux couleurs
du pousse à lire qui va ce qui va
déambuler dans l'île des loisirs qui va
proposer aussi bien donc des livres
physiques mais aussi des livres audio
donc entre 20 et 40 minutes et donc les
jeunes pourront se poser et écouter
effectivement des livres qu'on était
quand même pris ce même pas encore sorti
en exclusivité qui sortiront car
l'automne
quels sont les autres rendez vous
ponctuels comme ça que vous allez
organiser pour cette saison estivale
alors deux rendez vous importants le
ciné mobile donc un camion qui se
transforme en salle de cinéma 80 places
qui vient le 22 juillet avec trois
séances 14h30 17h30 et 20h30
et surtout le l'île de france fait le
théâtre avec la compagnie des tréteaux
de france qui est un superbe projet qui
mérite vraiment être connu donc c'est
assez fin août 24 août au 1er septembre
exactement sur la fin de la saison
exactement il ya aussi bien des ateliers
que des spectacles où c'est fait par des
comédiens professionnels nous faut
vraiment profiter c'est gratuit donc
c'est vraiment un très très beau c'est
l'une des projets compagnie
qui bouge en france tout à fait deux
sites prévus et à la direction c'est
comme comparer nucci qui est l'un des
plus grands comédiens ils étaient là
l'an dernier et c'est vraiment très bien
ce qu'ils font à découvrir à partir du
24 août jusqu'au 1er septembre à cette
compagnie
les autres rendez vous il y en a qui
sont proposés régulièrement aussi qu'ils
ne sont pas bons qu elle pendant sept
pendant cet été
qu'est ce qu'on pourra faire sur cette
île de loisirs de saint quentin voilà
les activités traditionnelles mais qui
s'enrichissent d'activité plus récentes
je peux parler notamment du bng ctions
keep la deuxième saison est ouvert déjà
depuis le mois de mars dans la très loin
d'ici on est du côté on n'a pas situé
sur l'île le loisir on est du côté de on
est tout près lorsque nous sommes
arrivés il y avait voilà lorsque nous
sommes arrivés il y avait effectivement
des personnes qui s'apprêtait à décoller
puisqu'on est à l inverse du saut à
l'élastique en fait on part du soleil en
éjecté en hauteur donc c'est une
activité nouvelle qui est gérée par le
parcours acrobatique en hauteur qui est
juste à côté de nous ça c'est pour
grégorien je sais que nicolas nicolas
landry était également très intéressé
quoi enfin leur art lui rendre alors la
boîte alors pourquoi pas l'essayer
pendant l'émission
pourquoi pas alors après pour les plus
jeunes
les gir même les très jeunes parce que
ça c'est une quelque chose d'important
conçoit développe et sur les loisirs les
activités pour les tout petits
donc le parc de jeu a été très renforcée
puisque les quasiment multiplié par
trois par rapport à l'aller passé avec
je dirais de nouvelles activités comme
chenilles et
bulle d'eau etc donc il mérite d'être
découvert de re découvert parce qu'il
n'a rien à voir avec ce qui était
proposé l'année passée et puis également
dans ce même parc qui est un lieu
j'irai de balade pour les familles et
pour les tout petits des trottinettes
électriques des voitures pour les 2 ans
voit même - en fait télécommandé par les
parents donc on peut proposer des
activités aux tout petits qui se
prennent pour des grands noms dans ce
parc et cela fait très plaisir
voilà donc un profiter de l'étang aussi
à leurs activités qui sont proposées
avec les temps donc vous devez voir à
côté effectivement on reçoit du nouveau
matériel mais on a surtout de démarrer
une nouvelle activité notamment annuel
le paddle que l'on avait essayé déjà
ponctuellement la dépasser donc par des
cours j'irai à la séance
balas a remporté un certain succès donc
on essaie de proposer maintenant des
animations à l'année donc c'est toujours
en location et ça permet toujours de de
prendre le vent on va dire de se
rafraîchir par ces périodes ensoleillées
un programme très vaste merci à tous les
deux d'être venu nous en parler de
dresser un petit peu le panorama de ce
qui est proposé ici à lille de loisirs
une fois de plus on vous renvoie vers le
site internet il s'est affiché et vous
aurez toutes les dates parce qu'il y en
a beaucoup et un des évènements pour ne
rien manquer